bonjour je m'appelle jean luc augustine
donc je viens de saint paul je suis
titulaire du permis b et je suis
véhicules et je recherche un poste de
responsable administratif de préférence
dans l'ouest ce qui suscite moins
d'intérêt pour ce métier c'est la
diversité des tâches qui rend le métier
enrichissant et épanouissant je suis
titulaire d'un bts assistant de gestion
pme pmi un bts comptabilité et gestion
des organisations et et d'un diplôme de
comptabilité et de gestion j'ai 15 ans
d'expérience dans plusieurs sociétés qui
m'ont permis d'acquérir et de développer
de solides connaissances techniques
mon expérience m'a amené à intervenir
dans le domaine de la comptabilité la
gestion l'administratif la communication
voire même dans le domaine commercial
j'ai travaillé dans plusieurs sociétés
aussi bien dans le btp que dans les
entreprises agroalimentaires en tant que
responsable administratif
si vous cherchez un collaborateur
polyvalent rigoureux efficace un homme
de confiance sur lequel vous pouvez vous
appuyer alors contactez moi je suis
votre homme
je serais ravi de vous apporter mon
expérience et pouvoir élargir mes
compétences je vous dis à bientôt